ん
うん
こんにちははじめ撮影です急にピンポンできて撮ったらトイレ貸して下さいって言われ
て
一例えっ4ウェイ折れちゃ入りたいだけだろうかうん砂や水完全に愛してるということ
で攘夷派だったんですけどもトイレ近くにどこがありますかって言われて
ひとまず僕に前机にコンビニがあるんでそこのコンビニで上映があるんでそっちに行っ
てくださいって言ったんですけど怪しいのちょっと
と何で見ると思いますけど普通日緞帳トイレ借りますかいますか
絶対言わねーよ絶対まねいるかなちょっと見てみよう外
tee
ないないないけど怪しい台風についてたいんだよな
ちょっとまず怪しいコミュに苦手たんですけどちょっと
声を出したいなぜお前は俺のトイレを使おうと思ったかっていうと聞いてみたいんで僕
もコンビニに行きますついでに昼ご飯です
ハーイ変態ですよ噛みそうなんだよああいうもうしわけです
誰だわーお仕事がんばってくださいありがとうございません
は絶対まぁあっはい
ええええええ
安全に1巻前見た完全には俺
いたよクソハロウィンだからてマリオのコスプレしてあったよ俺完全に来られたここ
からジジッ
だろう
[音楽]
湯川作たった the どっただいま見た完全に関係ないとかです話してくるよどう
すりゃ俺これって方がいいのかな
難しいな完全に僕んち来いとしてたんですよね愛着には取ったから逃げた顔すんだよ
もう
いなくなったら食べなくなったカメラ向けられたらやっぱ怖いんですよね人って僕も
盗撮されるの怖いのと一緒で
カメラを向けられると怖いんで多分逃げたんだと思いますこれでも来ないといいんです
けど
えーと今ツイッターちょっと見てたんですけど完全にそういうぽいツイートがありまし
たさっき3 editor もそうですか
そりゃあそうだよ花々からじゃないよもう完全に俺んツイッターさあ今の打ち上げ
ちょっと dm を送ってぼくんちにもう1回戻ってくるように言いますか言う奴は
どんな気持ちで俺んちに来てるのか
ちゃんと僕もねやっぱりいう時は言おうと思ったんでちょっと今日は説教島
がちです今日返事来るの待ちます
はい
まあいいやしたスキ
まあうそうですねあの
どなたですかやってます
[音楽]
まああります
あっっ
[音楽]
ウェーバー消えたんだけどこない
質のいい
したんだねぇ
分かりません今がちょっといきます
あのヤラセじゃないかなっ
都は今月は
どんなとですか僕のあります
うせ
youtube にありまして
はいさっきる twitter 送った設計です
それを来てない送ってない切ってるんじゃない
シェール層を受けたんですかねぼく+はも知れませんだ大胆伝えておりましたねうん
だけだしないって言い張っ
だ誰から聞いたの中学生
中学生かで言えるほどねあの本当
機嫌に来られると結構今尾編集しててさこういうのが続いちゃうと本当に迷惑すって
言っ
ねはいされ静岡もしてるの色は対象のトイレトイレも黄鯖からんですけどね
トイレ貸してくださいって言うのお前らーッ動画とってだけど出してもいいかわかん
黙ってくるんじゃないかな
あうっじゃあねつったら叩かれるけどまぁちょっとあーさーんっ
話しかけられたりすればいいんだけどさ家はプライベート伸ばせたかな
本当に嫌に来るのはいけないを見てますはい
しゃーすけどこれってですかこれはもうすぐ販売される日でドヴィレヴァンで
ああああ今ね喋って良かったら勝手に入っていくん
何だろうたぶんここに
テロップで出てるところです次から来たら通報することになるから
なるべくなるけどやめろやめだけど
動かしてくださいこういうファ
でありそれはもう来んじゃねえぞはいそれじゃあそれがたまったと言っちゃったんです
か
硬派やなぁまぁ悪いコマーシャルざ岩武克水も安い
最後のが合憲じゃねーぞはい偶然車
5迷っ
[音楽]
ん
バッハ
5を注意をしたんですけどあんまりこりでたさそうだった
本当に多分全員がのきた全部通報しますそく警察呼びますので
家には来ないで下さい愛的で真面目 t シャツと者数を t シャツとそれの
パーカーが8ヴィレッジヴァンガードそして web で販売されておりますあの
デザインがですね昔僕ディスティニーいいって書いてある2
シャツ着てた時あったと思うんですけどもありをデザインしてくださった
始めファンタジー3という形に作って頂きましたよかったら是非来てみてください
普通にあったかいか
まったく今日の動画関係ないけどね
me
ええええええ
あっ
はいそれもう一度いいですか